when I talk about this I make the
biggest mistakes is the red pill means
different things to so many people and
I've talked to like eight different red
pill creators all eight of them gave me
a different answer and so
I want to get too lost in the sauce here
but one of the things that we noticed
was that there's a very much difference
between traditional red pill and what we
consider Neo red pill okay we found we
found a little bit of a difference
between those two things but to me the
primary primary issue I have is a
representation of marriage because to me
like I said I believe that family is a
foundation of a society if we don't have
strong families people depend upon a
state there'll be a lot of different
issues so I want to build as many strong
families as possible and I truly believe
that touring men from building families
that's something that hurts me
especially seeing how in the black
community the breakdown of the family
has decimated the community and I want
to find Solutions instead of just focus
on the problem it makes complete sense
so you're saying uh the biggest flaw
within the red pill is their their view
parent viewpoint on marriage what do you
think is the biggest benefit for
learning the red pill content 100 so I
would argue the best benefit is more
traditional red pill versus Neo red pill
but the best benefit is removing you
removing the delusion of that Disney
Channel Fantasy you know I think what
happens is a lot of young men grow up
with this Disney Channel Fantasy you
find the One You're Gonna live happily
ever after there's gonna be no issue all
women are angels this you know this
delusional sugar and spice and
everything exactly so to me men growing
out of that delusion and that propaganda
that was promoted through Disney Channel
and the Hollywood movies and stuff like
that is extremely important for men to
flourish and thrive in life so you do
think it's important though that that
men understand the the drawbacks of
marriage too though a hundred percent
bro 100 and you do think it's important
that men should understand like female
nature too a hundred percent and so so
you would agree that it's this is really
important well I would I would disagree
I would agree and disagree Pearl okay um
so okay my question to you is who is the
individual you're going to to learn
about male and female nature
who me personally who do you go to oh
Mom and Dad okay
[Laughter]
um
so that's where you learned like
initially like when I was young like in
regards to like the red pill right so
yeah I thought you meant like okay yeah
because obviously like you you've come
to a transformation from my
understanding so when you're talking
about men learning about male and female
nature I'm curious to you where do you
go to to learn about male and female
nature in regards gosh you learn a lot
just from doing the freaking shows yeah
oh my God you know
you know how many girls cap on the show
oh my God like I feel like I really
started to understand the red pill just
from like interviewing people yeah
because I what four days a week seven
people in the studio like oh my that
change it changes your life oh my God
yeah what's the biggest lesson you've
taken away from interviewing all these
people especially women
oh I like nice guys and I'm like I saw
your ex-boyfriend I know like okay just
one girl I'll give you a story this girl
came on the show right
she she was so pretty so nice whatever
and the whole show she was talking about
how she only dates like you know the
nice guys like after the show
this like
uh my recruiter brought his friend and
he'd literally been to jail he took her
home that night
and so I was like the biggest lesson to
me was just like this is madness let me
just say things so okay so
listen and I will say not every woman
not all women but it's just like I feel
like that's like part of it the reason
why I asked you that question initially
is I'm I'm asking in regards to like
when you said learn about male and
female nature I'm saying like let's say
outside of the content because you
obviously learned about it where did you
go like what was it growing up like I
mean like you like from my understanding
you came to a conclusion about like man
society is getting crazy where did you
learn that from was there a book was
there have you been to a college campus
okay society's getting crazy yeah what
do you mean oh my gosh when I went to
college and I saw that they put these
dudes in our dorms and they're saying
that they were women
what do you mean so so you so from my
understanding you came to your as they
call it red pill awareness from life
so it was partially just from
sounds more like blue pilled before I
didn't really I never thought about
things from the men's perspective but
there was a couple pivotal Moments One
was going to a pickup artist conference
you told me about that yeah that I was
like oh my gosh
these these girls that are like twos are
rejecting the fives and harshly so that
kind of like puts you in a men's point
of view because I was like oh my gosh
um I can't even believe like what that
second thing um the rational mail I read
that I think I think Rolo's a genius I
think he's very smart
um his second book religion
um I think is good too yeah
um yeah so I also listened to months of
literally months of like manosphere
content like okay yeah yeah you can see
me reacting to it live yeah yeah we've
talked about this you brought up
something earlier that I want to address
you said that there's a difference
between like the old school traditional
red pill stuff which I think you would
put Rolo in that category and sort of
the neocons yeah so would you elaborate
on who you think is I don't know you're
saying like who's really doing the red
pill right and then who's sort of
hijacking the red pill like just clarify
what you mean by the old school versus
the New School radio content creators no
problem so um Chris Williamson talks a
lot about it Chris Shout out to Chris
Williamson respond to your messages
Hamza talks about this as well
um so what happened is a lot of people
um The Red Pill a lot it originally
donated the in the chat rooms so the
message boards the chat rooms so a lot
of people who were the initial red pill
um thought leaders they were they were
writers because you had to write in the
chat room which ones I'm just curious so
obviously Rallo was probably the most
popular ones and if I'm being completely
honest it was so long ago I didn't
really know their names I just would I
would just would read something you were
in the chat rooms of course of course
you were in the chat room with Rollo I
was no no I wasn't in the chat room to
roll up so long story short the reason
why I'm so passionate about this subject
matter is because I was like so many
guys man I was struggling with
relationships I had to move back home
multiple times like like the the typical
you know
average guy who's struggling in life
that was a lot of times my story so I
would seek out wisdom in many different
areas I started off with a lot of
Christian masculinity content so in the
year 2009 it was a Christian Renaissance
that created a lot of masculinity
content so I was consuming all kinds of
content for a long period of time and
during that time I also stumbled upon
the red pill message boards and so the
lit the original content creators in
retro message boards they were writers a
little bit more thoughtful and a lot of
them would quote at times evolutionary
biologists they would quote a lot of
these studies that came from like you
know pure research gallop and things
along those lines so those were the
traditionalists a lot of the Neo red
pills from my personal experiences they
don't quote the primary sources which
are the evolutionary biologists the
historians the relationship therapists
and the studies Rob Henderson what about
Rob no I was saying like that's one of
them right is that Rob Henderson's one
of what oh the people that you'd like to
see quoted I thought you said that last
time I'm sorry oh oh yeah no no Rob is a
red pill so that's a little bit
different I've at least said The
evolutionary biology oh yeah like person
like right I don't think Robert's
Evolution biologist in my opinion but I
could be wrong so I just I thought you
said him last time oh no problem no
problem no problem um and so with the
Neo red pillars they don't go to the
primary source they usually quote other
red pillars you know so they will quote
statistics and um of other people versus
going to the primary sources and so to
me that's why I distinguish those two
different things and a lot of the Neo
red pillars um they they came to content
Creation in a time when it was very
profitable to make content so the one
thing I will definitely give ralu is
Rallo was doing this when there was no
money here so I could give him that like
he there was no financial gain from him
I mean obviously he made good money from
his books but he was typing up and
talking about these things for years a
lot of the Neo red pillars a lot of them
came into when it was very profitable
um and so that so that I can't in my
community we distinguish those two
individuals if you would
um
let's get positive for a second let's
just be positive uh what do you see as
the biggest benefit for men
understanding intersectional Dynamics
red pill understanding how women operate
this is good give me the benefits you've
seen I wouldn't call it red pill I would
call it understanding evolutionary
biology so I would my book of choice for
every man is
um Dr David buss's evolution of Desire
Dr David Buss is a leading expert on
evolutionary biology and respective in
regards to human mating he's a
world-renowned expert he has a bus
School of Psychology in Austin Texas so
his book is absolutely phenomenal
footnotes data so I would say the
learning from the primary sources like
that give you the knowledge to not be
naive in today's world because to
Pearl's point a lot of men grew up naive
a lot of men don't really understand
what's going on a lot of men also don't
know the bad of marriages and
relationship as well so Dr David Buss is
phenomenal Dr John dotman in in in
Washington is a rock star he's been a
one of the leading experts on marriage
for the past 40 years Dr John gottman is
able to predict Divorce by 88 accuracy
you've seen him before he's obese so to
me those primary sources I love the
primary sources I don't I would consider
most red pill as secondary sources but
the actual doctors and experts and
people who've been doing this for
decades of their lives I think there's
so much benefit from running from those
individuals I'm gonna give you the same
question and then I'm gonna give you a
follow-up so just be ready for that uh
best benefits you see for men
understanding red pill content
um I just think a lot of guys have like
a
they don't see the negative side of
female nature and as much as like maybe
like you know you want to harp on saying
oh what about the positives too I just
think it's important that you see the
negative side of female nature so if
something happens down the line you're
at least not surprised and that you're
aware of the risks that come in marriage
okay I respect that now let's you're the
one of the reasons that you've had so
much success is that you're one of the
few women that are major Advocates as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible